Speaker 1: All right.
Last week, I interviewed Vincent Racaniello,
virologist from Columbia University, and he
said it does make some sense that countries
are starting to roll back COVID guidelines
and restrictions.
When you look at the U.K., when you look at
Israel, when you look at other countries,
it makes some sense because as this Omicron
wave goes down, it does seem like Macron is
significantly less deadly.
Doesn't mean everybody has only a cold.
But there are some reports that say the R
Macron death rate is 0.2 percent.
That would put it at basically flu, which
is zero point one five percent.
Vaccines widely available very good at preventing
serious illness and death are Macron tailored
vaccine coming in a few months, if not after
this wave than when is sort of the question
that is increasingly being asked.
Of course, bearing in mind, some people are
going to need to be careful for a long time
because of specific health situations.
Denmark is now going back to normal.
Denmark will end most COVID restrictions and
quote Welcome the life we knew before.
Denmark Prime Minister Medha Frederiksen announced
yesterday that Denmark will throw out most
COVID pandemic restrictions that it placed,
including masks.
Restrictions currently in place are for the
public to wear masks on public transit in
restaurants, shops, health care facilities
and retirement homes.
However, following the Feb. one change of
restrictions, which is Tuesday, masks will
only be required in hospitals, health care
facilities and elderly homes.
We say goodbye to the restrictions and welcome
the life we knew before, Frederiksen said.
As of February 1st, Denmark will be open,
according to Health Minister Magnus Handke.
Denmark's recent cases of COVID were more
than 46000 daily on average.
However, only 40 people are in hospital intensive
care units.
We continue with a strong epidemic surveillance,
then we can react quickly if necessary.
Despite lift of restrictions, Frederiksen
warned there could be a rise in infections,
which may lead to a fourth vaccination shot
being necessary, which other countries have
found doesn't actually make sense.
So there are certainly controversies here,
but this is a question many countries are
going to be faced with.
I don't pretend to know the answer.
One aspect of this that many doctors are pointing
to is if not after this wave, than when.
Because if this wave moves us to the endemic
phase where it takes on more of a flu like
seasonal trajectory with a lower death rate,
this secondary R Macron variant that now is
being looked at, which may be even more contagious
but even mild there, although we don't yet
know for sure, would push us even closer to
flu slash cold.
What do you wait for?
Is the question, and it's not for me about
are we now at no risk?
It's what milestone would we we be waiting
for if indeed, that's the trajectory, so I'm
not pretending to know what needs to happen,
but I am asking what would be the milestones
if not in another six weeks as the cases continue
to decline rapidly, if they do.
In many states, Massachusetts, for example,
cases are already down more than 50 percent
and declining very rapidly.
Nationally, they're declining a little less
quickly.
Globally, they're basically flat right now.
Globally, we're now at the peak rather than
beyond it.
So more and more countries going in this direction
doesn't seem the U.S. is close to it.
I think masks on planes and public transit
will be around for a while, but there may
be changes coming.
I'm curious to hear from you what direction
you think it needs to go.
You can find me on Twitter at David Pakman
and we'll be back right after this short break.
Hey, so we're an independent media show, we're
not part of some big conglomerate.
We, you know, every piece of equipment, every
health care dollar that goes towards paying
employee health insurance, you know all these
things.
They really come from you.
We're primarily funded by the audience, and
I would love it if you grabbed a membership
at join Pacman dot com to support the work
that we do and we want to do more.
This weekend, for example, we're going to
have multiple correspondents at the Trump
rally talking to Trumpists, helping us to
understand what's going on.
We can only afford to do those things and
more things going to debates and different
things as we get into the midterms.
We can only do it with your support, so please
sign up at join Packman dot com.
We've got a bunch of great member benefits,
including an extra show that we do every day
for our members.
And you can use the coupon code WOW 22 to
discount the membership to an even more shockingly
affordable rate at join Packman dot com.